paleontologists are making fascinating
discoveries in a remote China desert
skeletons stacked atop one another piled
four and five deep columns of death
finding bone beds that just have the
remains of small meat-eating dinosaurs
is extremely unusual and extremely rare
and extremely exciting
Raptors just stir the imagination the
Raptor found on top is a particularly it
is the largest one in the pit at about
three meters long and its features are
distinct the s-shaped neck typical of a
carnivorous Raptor the three fingered
claws of a meat-eater
it had carnivorous dinosaur teeth these
steak knife like teeth and then it had a
crest on its head they named him
guanlong meaning crested dragon the
scientists also notice a very
conspicuous Ridge on a hip bone of the
skeleton this telling trait along with
the unusual shape of the teeth leads the
team to an exciting conclusion they have
discovered an ancient to rena soar their
extraordinarily familiar of course
because of t-rex and its charismatic
qualities but they are a group that
shares a set of characteristics somehow
the tyrannosaurus t-rex t-rex was just
an enormous animal 12,000 15,000 pounds
gone long was you know waiting in the
hundreds of pounds
this is gonna be a much swifter animal
much more agile and running down prey
they probably went from being predators
of relatively small animals to predators
of bigger prey items with the capability
of breaking even bones with their teeth
the dig team works with biologists and
artists to bring guanlong to life every
bone tells a story but each needs to be
assembled into a skeletal form first
then they determine how the joints
connect and the range of motion they
would have allowed they add in tendons
and muscle mass and a cyber guanlong
comes to life it's obviously very
athletic creatures by looking at its
body form the arms have gone long or
quite long for the size of this animal T
Rex's arms were more like two fingered
stubs the interesting question is not so
much what was guanlong doing with its
arms but why did the weird arms of t-rex
evolved the way they did with the
discovery of guanlong the scientists can
now see to rena so revolution in action
the four loons became less and less
important in grabbing and grasping prey
and instead the head and possibly the
feet became more important in the
actions of catching prey animals